we are back now here at 7 30 and
starting this half hour with an
important story about Community Health
Care a story that many of you out there
are going to be able to relate to it's
the CBS News investigation that finds
Healthcare institutions that Americans
rely on are being taken apart and then
shut down by investors who are looking
for profits our investigation focuses on
one company in particular that made
millions of dollars and then clothed
some of its Community Hospitals leaving
patients scrambling for care it's part
of a larger trend of investors from the
world of private Equity snapping up
everything from local doctors practices
to specialty clinics and even Hospice
Care Centers our chief medical
correspondent Dr John lapuke is here
with the story John this is a big one
good morning
Good morning Tony for nearly a century
Delaware County Memorial Hospital in
Suburban Philadelphia delivered babies
treated trauma and tended to the
critically ill that all changed earlier
this year when its current owner a Los
angeles-based company called Prospect
medical Holdings began cutting services
first the Maternity Ward went then the
operating rooms and the ICU and then
last month the emergency room closed its
doors to the community's nearly 85 000
residents
this is what it looks like when a
hospital shuts its emergency room doors
Turning Away patients like Shirley Posey
I was having shortness of breath
um and tightness in my chest Latifah
Dixon and her two children showed up
after getting into a car accident they
too were turned away along with 28 year
old Cecilia viswete who was having
trouble feeding her one-year-old
daughter because of a breast infection
they said I should look on Google Maps
for another hospital
inside Delaware County Memorial the
hallways and patient rooms normally
bustling were empty except for a few
nurses charged with cleaning the place
out I cried I'll be honest I cried
emergency room nurse Angela Napolitano
is the president of the local union and
worked there for 41 years my children
were born there saved my Dad's life in
the emergency room so it's a part of me
Delaware County Memorial was part of a
non-profit Pennsylvania health system
that was in danger of failing when it
was purchased in 2016 by Prospect
medical Holdings a Los angeles-based
for-profit company with the backing of
private Equity investors Prospect
Medical's portfolio would by 2018 grow
to 20 hospitals in Six States after the
Pennsylvania purchase the company had
promised to invest 200 million dollars
to dramatically increase service to the
community they tried to tell us that we
were they were going to run us the same
way we don't worry trust us did they
actually say that to you instead
Napolitano says Prospect medical
dismantled the hospital piece by piece
leading to longer weights in the ER and
forcing staff to transfer more patients
to other hospitals they have been
cutting services things wouldn't get
fixed our elevator in the back of the
emergency room been broken for over a
year holes and walls not fixed and then
when they closed the ICU
that was a knife in my heart a CBS News
investigation found of the 20 hospitals
owned by Prospect medical five have
closed including this 89 year old
hospital in San Antonio laying off more
than 500 workers we wouldn't see a
hospital closing down if this was a more
affluent area Delaware County official
Monica Taylor says closing what's
considered a safety net hospital will
hit the area's low-income population
hardest what happens to a community when
it loses its only emergency room there
aren't resources nearby and so we find
that people wait longer to go to the
hospital it leaves a gaping hole in this
community that is going to be very hard
and very difficult to fill in a
PowerPoint provided to the county
Prospect medical cited High labor costs
record inflation and the covid-19
pandemic but according to Taylor the
company has been reluctant to share its
financials with the county you think
they've been leveling with you no I had
a sense that they were not giving us all
the info information they didn't care
about health care doctor what they cared
about was making money for their
investors Rhode Island attorney general
Peter narona says what's happening in
Pennsylvania is what Prospect medical
tried to do in his state where he says
the company drove two hospitals deep
into debt their hospitals were in real
danger of closing in 2019 narona
investigated a proposed company
transaction invoking State Law to force
Prospect medical to turn over its
financials and found it put every
hospital in its system at risk of
reduction in Services sale or closure
did they say look there was a pandemic
who could have predicted that and that's
really largely responsible well this had
nothing to do with the pandemic
hospitals all over the country were
facing the pandemic but the problems
here were exacerbated frankly by greed
two different outside experts followed
the money and discovered one reason why
the company was so far in the red summed
up in a ruling by narona in 2018 the
owners of prospect medical took out a
1.12 billion dollar loan using proceeds
to pay themselves and their private
Equity shareholders of 457 million
dollar dividend they basically took a
big loan out okay a billion dollar loan
out and took nearly half of that loan
and rather it then invest those loan
proceeds in the hospitals that they
owned put the money in their pockets as
dividends how do they try to pay back
that loan they sold the hospitals off
and leased them back so now you're even
in a worse position in Delaware County
that lease back Arrangement meant 35
million dollars a year in rent had to
come out of Hospital budgets this after
Prospect Medical's owners and private
Equity investors paid themselves that
457 million dollar dividend you know how
much that was no I don't it was 457
million dollars oh my God
that makes me want to cry it makes me
sick because
I should have went back into the
hospitals and into the community and
that whole time
that all this was happening they were
blaming the staff
and covet with the hospital now shut
down a judge next week will hear
arguments over whether to require
Prospect medical to find a way to reopen
its doors
what they've done is extremely
evil in my own words why do you think
it's evil because to gain a dollar
you've
maybe destroyed lives maybe even ended
lives because they can't get the help
that they need
in a statement to CBS News Prospect
medical said it's cooperating with
health officials and working to
transition Delaware County Memorial to a
behavioral health facility in an annual
report the company said it has lived up
to its commitment to invest 200 million
dollars in the Pennsylvania health
system Prospect medical CEO declined an
interview but the Rhode Island attorney
general told CBS news that the prospect
medical CEO's share of the 457 million
dollar dividend was about 90 million
dollars wow that's pretty jaw-dropping
what you just showed us it reminds me of
something that commissioner Bratton told
me years ago that something could be
awful but it's lawful so is this legal
what they're doing yeah I asked Peter
narona who's the attorney general for
Rhode Island is illegal he said at least
in his state it is but the big Point
here is the only reason why we were able
to follow the money is because attorney
general narona invoked an unusual state
law that forced the company to turn over
its financials and his advice to
everybody else out there is look there's
a lot of these deals going on and he
really encouraged other states to create
legislation that allows more
transparencies they can look behind the
curtain when these kind of deals uh
arrive so you don't think this is an
anomaly what what you just showed us you
know it's hard to know right because it
was a record year last year for for a
private Equity uh investing in health
care and uh you know we just don't know
because we don't have the money Trail
and all the others but you know it
leaves me with the thought what happens
when private Equity brushes up against
Health Equity look at the people that
are being hurt that's the thing that was
eye-opening and heartbreaking Dr John
lap thank you very much